welcome to the show we have to start by
talking about Donald Trump's convicted
campaign chairman Paul Manafort who has
been sentenced to only 47 months you
might remember he was facing 24 years
the recommendation was for 20 years he
got 47 months and this is so
representative of one of the biggest
problems with our justice system and
there's lots of people on the right when
the left talks about structural bias
systemic bias you have a lot of people
on the right who say find a specific
systemic or structural bias show it to
me and I will work with you to fix it
well let's fix our justice system
because that is an extraordinarily good
example the system works one way for
people who are mostly wealthy and/or
well-connected and/or typically white
and it works a completely different way
for people who are mostly not wealthy
not well-connected and not white the
maximum sentence for Paul Manafort was
24 years the recommendation was for 20
years and Manafort received 47 months
despite multiple serious felonies
despite obstructing the investigation by
lying after he signed a plea deal which
assumed his truthful and forthright
cooperation and the judge said yeah the
crimes are serious but he shouldn't be
imprisoned until he's in his 90s he's
about to turn 70 years old I believe
next month so I'm giving him 47 months
he gets credit for the last nine months
meaning he has 38 months remaining of a
sentence he does have to pay 25 million
dollars in restitution and a $50,000
fine these are sort of sympathetic
comments by the judge he is sympathetic
to the circumstances of Paul Manafort
given his age and his deteriorating
health that's actually fine if you
believe that our justice system should
be more sympathetic in general I'm right
there with you but as many public
defenders have pointed out since the
verdict including Rachel Marshall
in a really good op-ed in the Washington
Post her clients don't get this sympathy
she has represented people who have been
sentenced to life in prison for minor
offenses sometimes under what's called
the three strikes law for things like
stealing pants from Sears to later
return them fraudulently to be able to
get a car seat for a child okay and
under the three strikes law they have
been sentenced to life in prison and
when she has said to judges consider the
circumstances of my client
she has asked for that sympathy and
lenience and it's often poor clients
it's often but clients that are not in
privileged position sometimes histories
of drug addictions sometimes bad family
situations and she doesn't get that
sympathy and leniency that Paul Manafort
received for her clients and not only
that her clients often have to sit in
jail up to through and during their
trials now Paul Manafort eventually had
to do that for part of the time once he
broke his plea agreement by lying but he
was out on bail and able to prepare a
defense as a result of not having to sit
in prison Manafort had that privilege
which many poor defendants don't get so
the problem here that I have is not that
the judge was sympathetic to Paul
Manafort
specifically that's great we actually
need a system that's more sympathetic
and I will agree with anyone who says
hey you know what
in general we need a more sympathetic
and empathetic justice system the
problem is that the sympathy correlates
with the power and status of the
defendant the problem is not
specifically that manna fort got 47
months the problem is that the max was
24 years the recommendation was for 20
years
poor brown skinned defendants often get
if not the max but the recommended
amount of time manna fort received 19%
of the recommended sentence and only 16%
of the maximum sentence that's the
problem and over the last several years
on the show you might remember I've been
talking about the disparities in terms
of how the law enforcement
justice apparatus focuses on street
crime versus white-collar crime and
corporate crime and that's one
inequality but it's not the only
inequality think back also because now
we're talking about high-level crime by
people in positions of privilege or at
least access to information think of
Chelsea Manning okay Chelsea Manning
received a 35-year sentence for
revealing evidence of crimes committed
by the United States military via the
leaks that she participated in
orchestrated consider again how we treat
whistleblowers exposing criminality
versus in this case a guy who has been
committing crimes for a long time in
Paul Manafort directly commits connected
to the highest office of power in the
country that of the President of the
United States that's also a disgusting
inequality of the justice system but
maybe one that we will focus more on at
another point and then just as a
reminder this is just Paul manna for its
first sentencing he's still scheduled to
be sentenced in the other case possibly
as early as this week so we'll be
keeping an eye on that and we'll see
what kind of a sentence comes there but
on this first one forty seven months far
short about 85% short roughly 80% short
of the recommended sentence and 85%
short of the maximum sentence this is a
system with structural bias structural
inequality let's get together with the
Conservatives who claim they want to fix
those structural biases and let's fix it
for whatever reason they don't seem
actually like they're clamoring to do it